Congratulations, bladesmiths.
You've made it to the second
round of this competition.
And now that your blades
have been tempered,
it's time to turn them into
fully functional weapons
by attaching handles to them.
However, we've got
the added enjoyment
of including a hidden lanyard
hole in your pang design.
Good luck, bladesmiths.
Your three hours starts now.
Let's talk a little bit about
this recess lanyard hole.
The one thing that
I'm nervous about
is that these guys are
going to get into a focus,
and they're going to get their
glue on there, they're going
to put their pins, and
forget to give a little
hollow for that lanyard.
[chuckling] Welding.
The first thing I have
to do in this round
is fix this void by adding
material without heating it up.
But you can't do one
without the other.
If I apply too much
while welding this void,
it's going to ruin the temper.
Oh, no, no, no.
It's really easy to want to
cool off that weld quickly.
And what you wind up with
is a weld that's solid.
But the metal on either
side of that weld
is now brutal as heck.
BRENDAN: Dave doesn't like the
way this fits in his hands.
It's the weakest
part on the blade.
I can only remove so much
without it just snapping,
flying across the room.
And then it's back
to square one.
And square one will
be me scratching
my head in my own shop, reliving
this event over and over again.
Putting a hidden lanyard
hole in that the handle is
going to be no problem at all.
But I feel like
three hours is not
enough time for me to finish
the 500 things I have to do.
My biggest worry is, there's
no transition between my blade
and the handle.
I really need to resolve that.
So I'm adding a guard.
An unprompted
guard-- has that ever
happened here in the forge?
I've never done a
hidden lanyard hole,
but anything's easier
than a cold foge.
I chose G10 for the handle.
And I'm going to do a
little razzle dazzle.
This handle is going
to be beautiful.
Your cutouts on
your handle material
should curve, match up with
the back end of the hole,
and then curve
out again, so when
you push the lanyard through,
it just slides through the hole.
I'm grinding away
at the grinder,
and taking as much
meat and handle
off, because that's exactly
what they told me to do.
But to do a good
hook job, you want
a little meat on your blade.
So I'm going to leave
mine a little thicker
than the other guys.
I get a little advantage there.
Brendan has grabbed
some handle material.
It looks like
quarter-inch Micarta.
BRENDAN: This piece
looks like it's going
to be just the right thickness.
I won't have to
take away that much.
And then I gotta put a
nice little hidden pocket
so you can put a lanyard
through that lanyard hole.
What I'm doing is using
the natural radius
of this grinding belt
wheel to just router
out a sweet little pocket.
Now, the one thing I hope is
that that lanyard hole should
be bigger than a quarter-inch.
There's nothing worse
than having a lanyard hole
that it's really tough
to get a lanyard into.
That ain't bad.
I like it.
You have 60 minutes!
That's 60 minutes remaining!
BRAD: I'd glue the handle on,
and the holes don't line up.
I'm totally paranoid that
the epoxy was getting hard.
This could be a disaster.
[groans]
Oh, whoops.
[laughs] I realized I just
grabbed the wrong side scale.
Good thing I realized
that before the epoxy set.
It went together fairly well.
But it's crazy.
There's just not much time left.
I'm usually relaxed
at home doing all
this with some music playing.
I feel like a clock
is just killing me.
Bladesmiths, there are only
30 minutes left on that clock!
JEFF: The second round, and even
making it here, I'm in heaven.
I'm enjoying every minute of it.
It may not look like
it, but I'm smiling.
It looks like he's kind of
going with that nap look, where
you put a lot of little
dents and grooves
all over everything.
Done right, it can be a
pretty comfortable handle.
Done wrong, it's just a million
hot spots throughout your palm.
I fixed everything the
judges wanted me to fix,
and I'm just going to town.
I'm just cruising along.
MAN 1: It still looks
like a really beefy knife.
MAN 2: He seems to
like the heft of it.
But people also
think their babies
are cute when they're not.
[laughter]
JEFF: I think I've got the
best blade going in so far.
So I think I'm going
home to the final round.
10, nine, eight, seven six,
five, four, three, two, one.
Bladesmiths, drop your tools.
This round is over.
I'm confident that
I fixed the issues
the judges had with my knife.
But Jeff's handle
looks pretty sparkly.
I don't know.
Maybe he is Magic Mike.